some fans thought it would never happen
but netflix is finally bringing the
sandman to live action who is trusted to
bring the enigmatic dream to life and
who rounds out the rest of this all-star
cast watch this before you see the
sandman
netflix's the sandman is set to premiere
on august 5th 2022 considering that the
author himself once claimed to have
spent 30 years battling against bad
adaptations the fact that this series is
so close to release is incredibly
encouraging the series originally
entered post-production on july 23 2021
and then again on april 17th 2022 it's
unclear exactly why there are currently
two separate periods of post-production
but it was likely to make sure the
finished show will truly bring to life
neil gaiman's vision the average time it
takes for a feature-length film to go
from raw footage to the final product is
around six months to a year this
includes editing sound mixing color
correction visual effects and a host of
other processes that need to be
completed before the project's release
because the total run time of netflix is
the sandman will undoubtedly be much
longer than the average film it could
explain why there were two separate
phases in any case we can't wait to see
the dream finally make it to tv screens
on august 5th
tom sturridge takes on the role of dream
a powerful figure also known as morpheus
or the sandman dream is one of the seven
endless a family of beings who represent
different aspects of the universe he's
an immensely powerful character who
rules over a kingdom known as the
dreaming death as family
desire
destiny
despair though sturge will serve as the
lead of the series he's just one of many
familiar faces you'll see in the massive
ensemble cast of the sandman one of the
prominent roles in the series belongs to
kirby howell baptist who plays death in
the series she's most well known for her
roles in killing eve and the good place
then there's jenna coleman who plays
johanna constantine who in the comics is
the great great great grandmother of
john constantine the series will reunite
game of thrones alumni charles dance and
gwendolyn christie dance takes over the
role of occultist roderick burgess while
christy inhabits the character of
lucifer morningstar and the legendary
mark hamill provides the voice of mervin
pumpkinhead the list of actors is so
long it's hard to get into them all but
all told the cast of the sandman is
filled from top to bottom with some of
the most talented and well-known actors
out there
fans will be overjoyed to hear that
these beloved characters are in such
experienced hands
the story of netflix is the sandman will
follow the plot of neil gaiman's
original comic series at the beginning
of the story dream is captured by the
occultist roderick burgess and is held
captive for over 70 years dream's
lengthy absence wreaks havoc across the
universe as a whole and when he finally
escapes he is forced to set out on a
lengthy journey to restore order and fix
his past mistakes forgive me messiah the
palace the realm
they are not as you left them gaming
also clarified that the first 10
episodes of the series will cover the
first two volumes of the comic preludes
and nocturnes and the doll's house the
first volume follows dream as he
reacquires the magical tools that were
stolen from him during his imprisonment
the second volume is chiefly concerned
with a serial killer convention subtle
machinations from dream's sibling desire
and the emergence of a dream vortex
which could spell doom for sandman's
kingdom beyond these small details about
the plot information about the series
itself remains sparse though the
recently released trailer gives us a few
pretty significant clues about what to
expect in netflix's the sandman
the trailer for the sandman focuses
heavily on dream and his kingdom of the
dreaming from what we see in the trailer
it seems like dream is released from his
occult prison when two police officers
shoot at him and shatter the glass walls
that surround him from there we watch
him return to his kingdom and discover
that the dreaming has turned into a
decayed ruin in his absence we get a
brief glimpse of death dreams loyal
sister as well as the villainous john d
the latter of whom is holding a ruby
that fans will recognize as very
important to the plot of the original
comic finally we get a brief but
chilling shot of a man with bleeding
eyes who may be the corinthian a
malevolent nightmare who escaped the
dreaming during his master's absence
even though this first trailer is only a
teaser for what's to come we are still
able to extract a surprising amount of
story from it in any case the trailer is
certain to get plenty of fans excited
for the upcoming series especially since
it's taken so long to see this project
actually completed
the star studded sandman castles could
even rival denis villeneuve's dune in
terms of sheer celebrity wattage however
it took some time before the names
involved in the project were revealed to
the world when they were they arrived in
a gigantic batch that had the internet
chattering for better or for worse neil
gaiman wrote the casting announcements
as well as a brief description of the
characters and why the chosen actors
were right for the roles introducing
patent oswalt as matthew the raven
gaiman disclosed an interesting detail
about the actors casting explaining how
the sandman team searched for someone
who had the voice acting abilities to
make the audience invested in such a
peculiar character and was also a fan of
the comic book series gaiman revealed
patton was the first person we asked and
the first person we cast the day before
we pitched the sandman to netflix
considering the sandman and lucifer are
both netflix properties featuring the
same character many fans presumed that
tom ellis would play the devilishly
dapper lord of hell in dream's story
however when the casting news dropped it
was revealed that game of thrones actor
gwendolyn christie had been cast as
lucifer instead many people didn't
understand why ellis didn't get the role
since he was exceptionally popular as
the character and already had an
established fan base this is especially
true considering that the netflix
lucifer series is based on the comic by
the same name which was a direct
spin-off of the sandman answering these
fan questions on tumblr neil gaiman
addressed the reasons for ellis's
absence from the series he replied the
theology and cosmogeny of netflix's
lucifer is a long way from sandman's
it's inspired by sandman but you can't
easily retrofit the lucifer version to
get back to sandman if you see what i
mean it seemed easier and more fun to
have the sandman version of lucifer be
well much closer to the sandman version
of lucifer gaiman once again discussed
the issue on his twitter account
explaining how ellis version of the
character was too different by the end
of the show and far more lovable than
the sandman iteration in other words
christie's lucifer isn't meant to be
very nice or laughable those who've read
the sandman know the series plays an
important role in the overall dc
universe it isn't uncommon to see dream
and the others interacting with
characters such as batman or john
constantine constantine appears early on
in the sandman comic series when he
helps dream reclaim his magical pouch of
dreams and shortly after escaping
burgess's imprisonment many fans
expected to see the character appearing
in the series perhaps even with matt
ryan reprising his role as the
chainsmoking hellblazer however when the
cast was announced jenna coleman was
revealed to be portraying johanna
constantine with no mention of jon in
sight considering that coleman's
character appears in the sandman trailer
adapting a scene from the comics that
starred jon the more rowdy part of the
internet got into a tangle believing
that the character had been gender
swapped for the sandman however that
simply isn't true johanna was a
character created by neil gaiman as a
tribute and included in the original
sandman comics in the comics she's an
ancestor of jon and has her own
intriguing backstory in all likelihood
netflix also probably wasn't able to
secure the rights to use john
constantine in this series since the
characters tied up in other dc projects
in various stages of production we'll
have to wait and see just how johanna
fits in with the series
before desire was even cast there had
been many suggestions about who could
play dream's rebellious sibling on
screen many fans drew up their dream
lists of potential actors for this
pivotal part and some performers decided
to put their names in the mix as well
while twitter might be a platform that's
notorious for feeding the outrage
machine it can also open doors and
connect people in positive ways just ask
mason alexander park as revealed by neil
gaiman in the cast announcements for the
sandman park reached out through twitter
in the early stages of the casting
process they certainly must have
impressed gaiman and the casting agents
since park got the part
the sandman has been a long time in the
making much like its characters it has
gone through various shapes and forms
before finally settling on a netflix
series as soon as the decision was made
on what it would be the casting process
for the show became one of the most
important parts of the production
process however this wasn't a cut and
dry case of approaching the big name
actors they had in mind and auditioning
for the rest boyd holbrook revealed to
collider that he had to go through a
lengthy auditioning process to secure
the role of the corinthian he explained
i read the script and they were really
adamant about everyone auditioning so i
went in and then i didn't hear anything
until probably like september or
something like that anyways it was a
long process and the conversation just
started and they wanted to tape again
and they wanted me to meet with neil and
talk about just how the show was going
to be done
boyd holbrook wasn't the only one who
had to endure a long auditioning process
tom sturridge is another cast member who
didn't walk into the room and get
offered the role on the spot while
sturge might have an impressive list of
credits having appeared in the hollow
crown sweetbitter and mary shelley he
still had a long hard road to travel
before being cast in the sandman while
many actors wanted the role of dream
there were two legitimate contenders
that sturge had to battle for the part
according to collider palldark and
american gods actor tom york and colin
morgan who appeared in merlin and
belfast were tested for the role and
were given serious consideration since
york had worked on a previous neil
gaiman adaptation his fellow candidates
for the part of dream must have been
sweating that he'd be the front runner
fortunately for sturge he impressed the
right people and got the role in the end
you know the same way
he's a fairy story eddie
he's no fairy story he's back
while the sandman is positioned as a
dark fantasy series it does feature many
thought-provoking themes especially
about the meaning of life and death
anyone who has read the comics can
attest to this for example in the
sandman number 13 dream and an immortal
man known as hob meet up once every
hundred years to discuss humanity death
and everything in between it's a
thought-provoking series of
conversations that makes the reader
question many aspects of their existence
during a tour to discuss his career
gaiman revealed to the audience that
episode 6 of the sandman made him cry he
explained that even though he had
written the scene and knew what was
going to happen it hit him hard when he
saw it replayed in live action perhaps
the characters will dive deeper into the
themes that will have us all
experiencing an existential crisis after
watching the show the 2020 pandemic was
a strange time not only was there a lot
of uncertainty around everything
happening in the world but it also
caused millions of people to spend more
time at home some decided to bake banana
bread and experiment on tick tock while
others developed an unhealthy obsession
with netflix's tiger king series the
production of the sandman was also
impacted by the pandemic due to the
travel bans and restrictions on
in-person interactions netflix pushed
development timelines and had everyone
wondering what would happen next
neil gaiman revealed to entertainment
weekly that warner brothers paid tom
sturridge to not take another role and
stay on standby even though it wasn't
certain he would be cast as dream
additionally netflix decided to make use
of the extra time and encouraged the
casting team to look at every single
audition received gaiman explained that
he looked at over 1
500 auditions for dream before the
decision to cast sturridge was finally
made though fans may have wanted the
series to arrive sooner it seems like
this casting was a dream come true
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the sandman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]